- On this episode,
I talk about a bunch of
stuff, I gotta go fast.
Enjoy.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
(hip hop music)
What's up everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is 95 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Super exciting
to be here
on a Friday.
It's a beautiful day in New York City.
Played basketball yesterday.
Staphon and DRock teamed
up to make the video.
(snaps)
(ball bounces)
(hip hop music)
- I let go, I let go.
- You let it bounce.
- When I let go--
(hip hop music)
- Let's go.
- Whoo.
(hip hop music)
- Link in Facebook and in YouTube.
By the way, Facebook peeps
you just saw the share
button, call to action
before the show.
I am obsessed with the
amount of people watching
versus the amount of people sharing.
I do not like the quant data behind it.
I feel that you should love me more
and share it more.
So share it!
That was also for everybody
else who's watching
on any platform besides
Facebook or listening.
Yes, go home, find it on Facebook
and share it.
That's right, that's what you call
a right mother(beep) hook.
(laughs)
India.
Let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Jose says,
"Stuck at DMV New Jersey.
Sucks here.
What can they do to bring
themselves into this decade?
Online and off.
So antiquated."
- Jose, there's nothing they can do.
Now, let me explain why.
There's nothing they
can do because, I think,
I'm not even educated on this.
They are run by the state.
Which would make sense.
Which means it's political.
It's all the things that
I do not believe in.
And they won't fix it.
The only way that DMV's can be fixed
is if they go private
and are run by entrepreneurs
who then actually care about the customer
and will fire somebody
if they suck at the DMV
like everybody I've ever had.
And care about efficiency
and time and speed
and getting people out
and do things like bring in
Starbucks or Dunkin' Donuts
into the DMV to make
more money on the rent.
Or the arbitrage of making
a percentage of each sale.
You know, innovate and
care and give a crap.
All the things that government industries
and objects don't do
because it is not in
their best vested interest
because the people that can't innovate
and can't win in a competitive landscape
they default into doing
those things instead.
How's that for some (beep) fire?
It pisses me off, it's so crazy.
And I don't wanna be a hardcore like--
Honestly, I don't wanna
be a hardcore capitalist
on this issue.
And that was as hardcore to that side
of an answer I ever give
'cause I do think I blend
but like, I don't know.
If you don't incentivize
humans in some way
to do the right thing, you can't win.
And more and more, in a digital world,
I would say I'm more
passionate and more hardcore
about my points of view
on government agencies
and school today than
I even was 10 years ago
because there's alternatives.
I'm a pragmatic kind of
dude and I understood that
some of the things but now
there's so much innovation.
There's so many ways we can solve.
It's just, we're not incentivizing.
These are bigger issues than you and I
and so privatizing is the way
I think those would be better.
I really do and look, privatizing
has its own bad stuff.
I'm not one of these like,
everything should go that route
because I believe--
but in the same way that I believe
unions were really valuable
when the titans of the first--
By the way, I could see unions coming back
as an important thing as
we live through the second
industrial revolution but for right now,
while we're alive, take
advantage of these opportunities.
- [Voiceover] Anthony
says, "I recently learned
"about Facebook dark post.
"Yeah, I know I'm a little
late but there is tons of info
"about dark post on YouTube.
"There are also people
selling dark post courses.
"Would you pay for a course
"or use all the free info on YouTube?"
- Anthony, I would not pay for a course.
I would use all the information
on YouTube and other places.
I'm sure there's a ton of
white papers and SlideShares
and if you use that thing called Google,
you can find more stuff.
Dark posts are not that complicated
because you just need (laughs)
The usage of dark post
is not that complicated.
Is dribbling and shooting
a basketball complicated?
No.
Is using a screwdriver complicated?
You can learn those things.
Being great at them is
a whole different thing.
The way to be successful
in dark post on Facebook
is to understand the
psychology and salesmanship
it takes to create a
narrative to the end consumer
that you target that
predicates an action for them
to purchase something
that you want to happen.
That's hard.
That's analyzing data.
Interpreting it.
Then deploying it
with creative call to
actions that are the variable
of the success to it
against the right demo,
at the right time,
in the right vehicle,
around the right psychology.
That's hard.
Understanding how to make
an ad happen on Facebook
is not hard, everybody can do that.
That should take you 20 minutes,
two hours or four hours,
depending on how you
learn to figure that out.
It's, are you good enough
to then make it happen.
So, no do not pay for a course
because you'll get that
information for free.
What you should do is get educated
on being at the bigger picture at hand.
Which is the craft of
the usage of the tool,
not the tool itself.
- [Voiceover] Dr. Laurie asks,
?Do you ever have dreams at
night about your business?"
- Dr. Laurie (laughs).
I think I've had too--
I mean, I dream about
business all the time.
Even though I go to sleep and I'm like,
okay dream about Jets Superbowl
and in like two seconds
I'm like in a meeting
with Stunwin, you know.
(laughs)
Not as much as I am.
I dream about business all the time.
And then I dream about all sorts of stuff
but I don't recall most of my dreams.
I'm not sure what percentage
of dreams I can recall.
What percentage of your dreams
do you think you recall, Steve?
- 25% maybe, not a lot.
- [Gary] India?
- More like 5%.
- [Gary] Staphon?
- [Voiceover] 2 1/2% percent (laughs)
- [Gary] DRock?
- [Voiceover] Same, two.
- By the way, I think all
four numbers are grossly high.
I think if you net, net the game out,
I bet you it's like .00 something.
If you think about how many dreams
you probably have in a night.
Oh, I bet you there's--
Google it up somebody, real quick.
I bet you the number's insane.
And then if you think about
how many nights you sleep,
you know, all of them.
I think you're gonna be far,
far, far pressed to get to 25%.
- [DRock] About a hundred, you know
a hundred something dreams.
- What's your first Google result?
- [India] Some people dream
at least four to six times per night.
- Great.
- All right, so maybe a little--
(laughs)
- Concept.
- [Steve] I can be dreamer, that's fine.
- He's a dreamer, folks.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] Fwarg asks,
"How can the communications
"manager of a nonprofit
on a heavy topic such as
"human trafficking make the
depressing content dynamic?"
- Fwarg, I think the
first thing you need to do
is make sure that you realize the content
doesn't have to be dynamic.
Right, I think everybody thinks like,
ugh, how do we make it social.
How do we make it fun?
Certain content has to
be done a certain way.
It's contextual.
I mean, this is really hardcore stuff
that you're dealing with.
I actually think the content needs to be
educational while not being
too complicated.
I mean, it's a depressing manner.
You're not gonna be able
to light it up, right.
You need to focus on what it is and so
I would educate and create
narratives through white papers,
infographics,
SlideShares,
videos,
pictures,
quote cards
that actually educate the market.
None of us here,
none of us here,
and when I say here, I mean everyone
listening and watching.
I would argue that less
than one percent of us
are really educated on the matter.
So how do you get the information out?
And I don't think that
it needs to be dynamic.
I think it needs to be truthful
and it needs to be
contextual to the platform.
Is that a 45 second video on YouTube
with the right tone music behind it
that is giving me the information?
Is that an infographic
with the right color tones
that aren't bright orange and--
I don't think bright orange
and yellow and sparklers
on my Pinterest board
around this subject matter.
And so I think,
I think respecting subject matter
and making in contextual for the platform
are way more important
than pigeon-holing yourself
in a world where you see other people
having the option to be
dynamic in a social media world
and you wanting to be
in that world because
either you want to be there
or two, you think that's the way to win.
I think the best way to respect content
is to respect the content.
And I think that matters.
- [Voiceover] Thomas
asks,"Would you be willing
"to sacrifice your ethics
for a business win?"
- Thomas, this is a great question.
As you know, it's because
of the #AskGaryVee Show
and how busy I've been, I
haven't been answering a lot
of the #AskGaryVee, if any,
of the #AskGaryVee questions
as they come through my Twitter feed.
But I answered that one pretty damn quick.
India, give me the call on
how fast I responded to that,
in minutes or days.
- [India] Looks like less than...
- Less than a couple minutes, good.
And the answer was a big, fat no.
And by the way, I'm gonna break this down
into an interesting place.
So it's not only no because
I wanna live a noble life
and be a good dude and
like ethics matter to me,
and my legacy.
I think everybody who
knows me, knows my legacy.
I'm obsessed with my legacy.
Over the currency.
So that would be that factor.
But it's also because I actually think
it's practically the right thing.
I'm a big fan, right
of the slower-hedged money.
I feel like I make more money
if I don't grasp at the money
that's in front of me and so
one of the biggest reasons
I won't break my ethics is,
if I do break my ethics,
the people that I'm building
around me would see that.
You know, my assistants
see everything that I do.
They've complete ac--
Steve, you access to my inbox?
- [Steve] I do.
- Steve has full access to my inbox.
If he sees, you know, it's
hard to do anything now
not documented.
If I do something that breaks...
At this point he as a good
sense of what my morals are
and how I roll.
He would, if he saw me do something,
even if it didn't have
anything to do with his world
or the stuff that we do together,
that breaks that compass,
he would then have to question everything
that I've established with
him as a moral compass.
Which would then lose
the trust that we have.
Which would then slow us down
in all the speed that I value the most.
It's speed.
The fact that this whole team here,
and this whole collective team here
and you as a team here
don't have to, once you get to know me.
Once I can get over that hump.
Don't have to then question anything
from a moral or emotional standpoint,
it adds to the speed of everything.
That's what a great culture is.
It's speed.
You're not spending the 15
minutes a day bickering.
You're not spending the four hours a day
wondering if that person's
trying to ruin you.
You're not doing those things
which then lets you go fast.
And fast, fast, my friends
is the oxygen of winning
the big, fast, important game.
See it's even a game called fast.
You have to be fast. (laughs)
So for me, it's really
important that everything breaks
the second I make that kind of decision.
And there's just not enough money.
I mean, I guess there's enough money,
everybody has a price. (inhales deeply)
A trillion? (laughs)
A trillion would feel--
and you know what's even funny?
It's funny, even if Zach came
out of my mouth, I don't know,
I don't know, I'm gonna end up,
I'm gonna end up leaving a
lot of money on the table
in my life because that's
not the way I score myself.
I score myself on number
amount of people--
The matrix of the number amount of people
that come to my funeral
and the business success
that I was able to create.
I'd be lying if was just about
everybody showing up to my funeral
but then I was like, didn't
win in this game that I played,
scored in business growth,
dollars, all the things, the game
But a hefty push to that funeral number.
Again, recently,
unfortunately in a tech space
we had a beloved character pass away
of CEO of Survey Monkey
that a lot of people knew.
A lot of my friends knew him really well.
I didn't really know him
well but it was interesting
how I was affected by it
just watching the outpouring
of what kind of a mensch,
what kind of a great human being he was.
I'd be lying if I didn't say,
"Wow, that's a little bit
of a preview of what I
want at scale as well."
And so, you know it's funny,
I literally said a trillion
and I'm taking it back.
I just can't go there.
It's just not the way I want
people talking about me.
- [India] That's it.
- Yeah, cool.
Question of the day.
What percentage of dreams
do you recall?
(laughs)
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)